[Musique]
bonjour à tous très heureux de vous
retrouver pour un nouveau numéro de
Parlement Hebdo l'émission qui revient
sur l'actualité de la semaine au
Parlement et pour commenter cette
semaine très riche nous accueillons
Rachid themal bonjour bonjour vous êtes
sénateur socialiste du Val-d'Oise trois
actualités à la une pour vous et dans
l'actualité parlementaire cette semaine
un examen de la réforme des retraites
qui commencent à l'Assemblée nationale
en commission avec 7000 amendements
déposés dont 6000 de la part des députés
de gauche le projet de loi sur les jeux
olympiques Paris 2024 examiné au Sénat
la majorité de droite à valider les
mesures concernant la sécurité de
l'événement et notamment à
l'expérimentation de la vidéo augmentée
pour surveiller les foules et puis les
députés les sénateurs ont trouvé un
accord sur le projet loi qui accélère le
développement des énergies renouvelables
les élus locaux auront désormais leur
mot à dire dans l'implantation des
éoliennes sur leur territoire
la réforme des retraites est donc
arrivée à l'Assemblée nationale et
députés vont scruter chaque point du
projet de loi de finance rectificatif du
budget de la Sécurité sociale c'est le
texte qui contient la réforme alors
voyons qu'elles sont les différents
groupes les positions des différents
groupes politiques avant la grande
bataille c'est un sujet signé Elsa
mondingava
une réforme des retraites dont tous les
esprits dans la majorité on tente de
déminer certains sujets comme la
question des femmes je ne peux pas
laisser dire que notre projet ne
protégerait pas les femmes
nous demandons à celles et ceux qui le
peuvent de travailler progressivement
plus longtemps y compris des femmes qui
ont eu des carrières complètes cependant
cependant les femmes continueront à
partir plutôt que les hommes j'ajoute
que les femmes bénéficieront de
meilleures pensions à gauche les groupes
de la nuque affinent leur stratégie
déposer des amendements mais sans faire
forcément d'obstruction objectif aller
au moins jusqu'au vote de l'article 7
celui sur le report de l'âge légal on
veut que le débat ait lieu sur le point
clé qui est l'article 7 et l'article 7
c'est de leur rallongement de deux ans
et on veut pas que le gouvernement
utilise le faible temps de parole pour
ne pas pouvoir discuter du lors de la
réforme qui est de la Contre-Réforme qui
est cet article 7 sur le report de deux
ans le RN lui entend marqué son
opposition ferme à la réforme mais
sans haut dans l'émission ni appelé à la
mobilisation dans la rue et la droite
dans tout ça les 62 députés les
républicains sont les arbitres de la
réforme mais apparaissent chaque jour un
peu plus divisé top départ de l'examen
en commission des affaires sociales
lundi 30 janvier en séance dans
l'hémicycle l'indice février et nous
sommes donc avec Rachid temal qui est
par ailleurs président délégué du groupe
socialiste au Sénat en Rachid themal
7241 amendements ont été déposés à
l'Assemblée nationale plus de 6000 venus
des opposition dans la majorité certains
réclament aussi de revoir et de corriger
le texte est-ce que vous croyez qu'il
est encore possible d'améliorer cette
réforme telle que présentée par le
gouvernement d'abord il faut dire
pourquoi il y a cette réforme je
rappelle que le président du Conseil
d'orientation des retraites la dit
lui-même dans lors d'une audition à
l'Assemblée il y a pas nécessaire de
réformer le système il n'y a pas
nécessité mais la réforme
aujourd'hui on a le droit de dire que il
y a pas nécessité contrairement à ce que
nous a dit gouvernement pendant des
semaines et des semaines il y a pas de
il y a pas périment à demeure puisque le
système peut perdurer moi je pense que
la seule réforme qui serait aujourd'hui
envisageable et sérieuse c'est
d'améliorer le système par exemple
aujourd'hui vous savez bien que l'homme
qui a retiré la pénibilité de la
retraite s'appelle el Macron quand il
est tout le Président il faut remettre
la pénibilité pour que les gens qui ont
déjà difficile par plutôt il y a la
question de du différentiel homme femme
donc il faut que les femmes aussi on
leur permet d'avoir un meilleur retrait
c'est ça qu'il faut porter il y a
beaucoup d'amendements justement qui
proposent à partir du moment vous
rentrez dans la mécanique vous rentrez
un macadies je dis aujourd'hui il y a
aucune nécessité de faire cette réforme
pourquoi je le dis le président du corps
l'a dit mais aussi un autre élément
regardez c'est un texte budgétaire en
fait aujourd'hui ce que propose Macron
et sa majorité c'est finalement à terme
puisque c'est de maintenir le niveau de
pension le monde le monde le montant de
la pension global dans l'économie c'est
à terme une baisse des pensions donc
nous sommes opposés et c'est normal à
cette rayon social pendant très
longtemps les gens terminent d'un mot
les retraités en France étaient ceux qui
étaient le plus dans pauvreté la réforme
que nous connaissons en France a permis
pendant des années des années de les
améliorer aujourd'hui ne sont plus les
plus grands les plus pauvres de notre
pays c'est une bonne chose avec cette
réforme là non seulement vous aurez une
vie plus précaire mais en plus une
retraite d'autant plus précaire et c'est
donc inadmissible inacceptable alors il
y a une solution qui est proposée par
les députés d'opposition de gauche et du
rassemblement national un référendum
avec le dépôt d'une motion référendaire
est-ce que le référendum ça peut être
une sortie à se débat sur la réforme des
retraites le vrai la vraie sortie
d'ailleurs ce serait plutôt de la
retirer la réforme ce serait de la
retirer d'ailleurs vous avez vu que
Franck Reister lui-même a expliqué que
pour les femmes seraient encore plus
pénible et bien tout ça n'est pas
sérieux je pense que maintenant il faut
retirer et aujourd'hui très hautement
quand on parle ce qui se passe dans les
EHPAD à l'occasion la ressortir un
bouquin il aurait mieux mettre de
l'argent et de l'énergie du gouvernement
à faire en sorte que dans les EHPAD les
les gens qui sont dans le grand âge plus
mieux vivre plutôt que d'aller
aujourd'hui faire une retraite qui est
une régression sociale donc moi je suis
pour surtout le retrait de cette
mauvaise réponse justement vous vos
collègues à l'initiative le députés
communiste il y a une motion qui sera
discuté lundi juste avant que ne
commence la discussion générale il
semblerait que ce ne soit pas forcément
gagné si je puis dire pour le
gouvernement parce qu'elle a des chances
de pas dire parce que ça veut dire que
la réponse est suspendante c'est pas ça
le sujet ce que eux ils sont et c'est
normal ce qu'on fera ici quand vous êtes
parlementaire parce que je suis quand
vous arrivez dans le Parlement vous
faites avec les outils qui sont les
vôtres
cette notion je vous rappelle
qu'aujourd'hui quand j'entends bon
nombre de élus de la majorité
présidentielle relative à l'Assemblée
quand j'entends également certains même
du modèle on se dit qu'ils sont déjà en
majorité relative donc il y a une
possibilité donc moi qui que mes
collègues fassent là je suis favorable
je vous dis simplement qu'en tant que
responsable politique je suis je dis au
gouvernement arrêter cela qui n'a aucun
sens et qui va juste encore une fois
paupériser les Français après
l'allocation chômage qui a quand même
fait plus 900 000 Français qui ont été
paupérisés et nous sommes dans une
situation économique sociale mental
difficile cette réforme là en finalement
c'est une régression sociale qui n'a
aucun sens et aucun fondement en tout
cas comme le démontre le président du
corps alors après avoir demandé le
retrait de cette réforme et ce qu'au
final quand même les sénateurs
socialistes vont proposer des
améliorations de la réforme notamment
sur les situations des femmes qui
seraient plus impactés par le report de
l'âge légal de départ là les élus
socialistes nous étions dans la rue à
l'initiative des syndicats nous serons
et j'appelle tout le monde allait être
ce mardi encore massivement parce que
vous regardez les sondages de semaine en
semaine vous voyez bien que le nombre de
Français oppose à cette réforme ne cesse
de croître et de grossir donc il faut
qu'on puisse ça après nous ferons si la
réforme devait venir au Sénat nous
ferons effectivement notre boulot nous
pouvons des propositions bienveillantes
c'est normal c'est ce qu'on appelle le
rôle du Parlement et donc le rôle de du
Parlement c'est aussi d'amender les
textes de se poser quand il y a
s'opposer de voter quand il faut voter
justement le ministre du Travail a
indiqué vous a indiqué à vous sénateurs
que les mesures sur la pénibilité sera
prise par décret est-ce que pour vous
c'est acceptable ou pas
il est sûr de il veut le faire voter et
ce qu'il y a de moins pire on verra plus
tard d'ailleurs j'entends tous ces gens
là ils sont les mêmes qui ont retiré la
pénibilité comment les croire je
rappelle que sous François Hollande il y
avait des critères de pénibilité qui
avait été inscrit dans la loi et quand
Emmanuel Macron a été élu président et
les a retiré donc comment puis-je croire
quelqu'un qui a déjà fait le contraire
de ce qu'il en train de dire les
Français ne sont pas dupes les Français
ont de la mémoire donc ce gouvernement
là c'est celui qui a durci la vie au
travail des Français et qui propose
demain de durcirer la vie alors la
retraite c'est quoi il faudrait partir
de là d'ailleurs la retraite c'est le
moment de la vie en bonne santé vous
pouvez vivre après 30-40 ans de travail
peut-être on peut partir de cela
aujourd'hui quand vous avez des
différences de entre 6 et 9 ans entre un
ouvrier et un cadre d'une vie en bonne
santé à la retraite et alors il faut
partir de cela moi je serai pour partir
à l'autre sens d'espérance de vie vous
dites en bonne santé en bonne santé
parce que vous savez c'est pas la même
chose et donc si vous partez de cela
vous verrez que tout le débat il faut le
faire dans l'autre sens autre mesure
qu'on évoque pas le travail des seniors
moins d'un seigneur sur deux au moment
de son âge de son départ à la retraite
est encore dans l'emploi c'est à dire
que la perspective qu'on donne à nos
seniors c'est vous allez travailler des
années durant vous terminerez au chômage
voire au minima sociaux et maintenant
leur dira à cette vous allez en plus en
prendre pour deux ans de plus il y a
aucune mesure par exemple qui fait que
demain les seniors restent dans l'emploi
ça c'est une vraie mesure sanctionner
les entreprises qui n'embauchent pas
assez de seniors le monde n'est pas
binaire moi je vous dis pas qu'il faut
sanctionner je dis qu'il faut déjà
mettre les il faut déjà se dire que
c'est une priorité plutôt que c'est
détruire la retraite pour faire c'est
une priorité alors on met tout
simplement les acteurs toute la table ce
qu'on appelle le dialogue social moi je
suis socialiste je suis pour le dialogue
social c'est pour le compromis social
moi je crois que les syndicats
d'employeurs et les syndicats de
salariés peuvent se mettre autour de la
table pour essayer de travailler sur ces
questions là on pourrait commencer par
cela ça pourrait changer parce que dans
ce cas là
on n'aurait pas cette fin de vie au
professeur au travail dégradante sans
dignité on peut pas imaginer des gens
terminent quand même vraiment encore une
fois au chômage au minima sociaux après
avoir donné toutes ces années au à la
collectivité voilà moi ça c'est des
vrais sujets c'est à mon avis ce qui
m'importe le plus que essayer de reculer
l'âge seulement pour pouvoir avoir une
mesure budgétaire
le gouvernement de retirer cette réforme
que vous estimez injuste
voilà votre position alors il y aura une
grande journée de mobilisation mardi
prochain vous serez dans le cortège
comme la dernière fois dites-vous est-ce
que d'ici là si les grèves continuent à
monter et si notamment le blocage se
fait sentir dans le secteur de l'énergie
est-ce que vous pensez qu'au vu de ces
éléments le gouvernement veut faire
plier ce qu'on pensait que la grève et
notamment le blocage dans les
raffineries peut faire plier le
gouvernement ou pas je pourrais vous
dire que il y a déjà eu une tentative de
réforme des retraites
et qu'elle a été retirée par le passe le
gouvernement là mais le gouvernement à
l'époque je dois Philippe mais c'était
sous la présence bien sûr de d'Emmanuel
Macron et enfin moi je vois quand vous
avez
je vous rappelle que il y a aussi une
crise économique sociale sans précédent
actuellement et que pour beaucoup de
Français je veux dire ce qui reste le 15
du mois dans le frigo c'est que la
lumière donc je veux dire c'est pas
améliorer pour la vie des vraies gens
donc aujourd'hui c'est toujours la crise
ce que le valma deux options soit il
entend pardon ce que disent des Français
qui majoritairement dans tous les
sondages sont opposés à cette réforme là
moi j'espère mais quand je vois la
dernière séance cette semaine du
gouvernement c'est assez UBS je prends
un exemple concret non essayez toute la
semaine et notamment lors de sa question
là de nous expliquer sur la question de
la retraite pour les femmes on n'avait
pas compris la seule personne qui a donc
manifestement pas bien compris la
réforme c'est Franck Riester puisque
c'est lui qui a dit ça donc même au sein
du gouvernement vous voyez bien qu'il y
a quelques difficultés donc je pense que
maintenant il faut raison garder je
pense qu'il faut plutôt relancer
l'économie je pense qu'il faut permettre
aux gens d'avoir un meilleur niveau de
vie et c'est pas cette réforme là qui
contribuera donc il faut la retirer et
mettre de moyens plus dans d'autres la
question de la sécurité la question de
l'école la question des retraites la
question des EHPAD il y a beaucoup de
sujets sur lesquels on peut avancer dans
cette contestation est-ce que par
exemple la mère de Paris à Hidalgo est
dans son droit quand elle dit que ce
mardi elle va fermer la mairie de Paris
pour protester contre la réforme des
retraites est-ce que c'est le rôle d'un
maire de prendre cette décision en tout
cas je rappelle que la mère de Paris
elle est aussi employeur
bon et donc elle a le droit comme tout
d'abord comme tout individu comme tout
tout élu comme tout français et en tant
qu'employeur d'avoir un mouvement de
dire je suis opposé parce que il y aura
des conséquences moi je vous donne un
autre exemple dans mon département j'ai
un maire et l'air très simple il est
l'air lui il est contre cette réforme là
il dit parce que il y aura un coup pour
le maire la collectivité et dit jusqu'à
ce que ça s'arrête je n'ai plus de
relation avec l'État ouais donc il est
aussi dans son bon droit vous voyez pas
de polémique inutile à mon avis
là-dessus et moi je crois que Anne
Hidalgo a raison de faire cela de dire
je suis opposé à cette réforme là et je
permets également au salaire qui le
souhaitent de manifester et
symboliquement je fais c'est cette
fermeture rachithémale au sein du Parti
socialiste sur cette question des
retraites certains défendent comme
Olivier Faure la retraite à 60 ans alors
que d'autres sont plus pour le maintien
à la retraite à 62 ans comme vous comme
le président du groupe socialiste au
Sénat Patrick Canet comment vous
défendre est-ce que vous reconnaissez
qu'il y a une division au sein des
parlementaires socialistes sur cette
question des retraites moi le seul texte
que je connais c'est celui qu'on a déjà
voté il indique pas 60 et 40 minutes
donc moi je reste à ce qu'est la
position du Parti socialiste vous êtes
pour le maintien 62 ans ou le pour la
retraite à 60 ans non moi je suis pour
là je n'ai pas alors là je dépasse ma
question c'est sur deux ans je suis pour
l'intégration massive des questions
parce qu'il y a des comment les gens ont
soit ils ont déjà les quarantaine unités
soit on considère que la pénibilité est
tellement telle qui peuvent partir avant
qui pourrait partir avant 62 ans oui je
pense qu'il faut arrêter d'être
dogmatiques moi je crois que quand vous
regardez
par exemple quand vous entendez ce qui
crie historiquement la CDT sur la
question des choses à la retraite par
point la question de la pénibilité etc
il faut entendre les choses moi je dis
simplement que aujourd'hui la position
du partialiste sauf à ce qu'elle soit
démenti par un autre vote au congrès ou
je ne sais pas c'est comme ça ça se
passe les militants historiquement ils
ont voté cela et vous n'incarnez pas
vous sénateur socialiste une autre ligne
que celle qui existe actuellement à
l'Assemblée au sein des députés
socialistes qui ont été élus sur la base
de l'accord avec la nupes
et en fait vous parlez d'un accord
électoral pas de problème et je veux
dire je n'ai pas entendu chez mes
collègues de l'Assemblée de dissonance
avec ceux du Sénat c'est que ce soit au
Sénat ou à l'Assemblée il y a de la
diversité d'ailleurs même au Sénégal il
y a de la diversité vous verrez dans les
débats vous verrez débats je crois qu'il
y a une diversité chez nous mais ce qui
compte en fait ce qui compte en fait
c'est que aujourd'hui on se parle n'est
pas de savoir ce qu'on propose comment
elle forme nous disons que la réforme
proposait le gouvernement est une
régression sociale et nous sommes tous
opposés à cette réforme à 64 ans tel que
le propose également pour vous pour
finir sur le PS il y a pas de fracture
politique qui se ressentirait
parlementaire il y a une unité totale
des parlementaires socialistes et même
des socialistes dans leur ensemble sur
l'opposition à cette réaction sociale
que propose du gouvernement on va
maintenant parler des Jeux Olympiques
Paris 2024 puisque les sénateurs ont
examiné cette semaine le projet de loi
qui prépare l'organisation de
l'événement avec notamment des mesures
sur la sécurité qui ont fait débat dans
l'hémicycle Jérôme Rabia
on pouvait penser à un texte dédié au
sport mais il a surtout été question de
sécurité lors de l'examen du projet de
loi sur les jeux olympiques à Paris en
2024 le principal débat apporté sur
l'introduction d'une nouvelle
technologie pour surveiller les abords
de l'événement planétaire grâce à des
algorithmes qui traitent les images de
caméras de surveillance les forces de
sécurité pourraient automatiquement
détecter des situations suspectes mais
pas collectées de données personnelles
promet le gouvernement pas question pour
le gouvernement d'aller dans la
quatrième catégorie qui est souvent cité
en exemple qui est celle de la
reconnaissance faciale mais de se donner
les moyens tout simplement de détecter
le cas échéant des mouvements de foule
un colis abandonné éventuellement des
armes longues mais pour les opposants à
la mesure communiste et écologistes en
tête ce nouveau dispositif va trop loin
et surtout l'expérimentation va s'étaler
sur deux ans jusqu'en 2025 soit bien
après les Jeux Olympiques une loi
d'exception qui mise à pérenniser un
coup de canif supplémentaire dans nos
libertés publiques la CNIL précise
d'ailleurs qu'il est nécessaire de se
prémunir de tout phénomène
d'accoutumance et de banalisation de ces
technologies de plus en plus intrusives
l'article prévoyant cette
expérimentation a finalement été
largement adoptée autre point de
vigilance des sénateurs le nombre
d'agents de sécurité disponibles pour
les JO il en faudra 22 000 selon les
organisateurs
interrogés sur le sujet le ministre de
l'Intérieur n'a pas totalement exclu le
recours à l'armée mais seulement dernier
recours dit à la fin des fins des fins
des fins des fins il manque un certain
nombre de personnes nous regardons ce
que nous pourrons faire mais nous
pensons nous qu'un grand pays comme la
France est capable de répondre à cet
enjeu de sécurité privée le Sénat aussi
beauté l'augmentation des peines contre
les militants qui s'introduisent sur les
terrains de sport autant de mesures qui
doivent être définitivement votés mardi
par le Sénat avant que le texte ne soit
transmis à l'Assemblée nationale
rachithéâtrement à vos autres collègues
à sénateurs de gauche les sénateurs
en gros si l'utilisation des drones donc
ce que nous disons nous nous disons la
difficulté c'est comment c'est d'abord
un le temps puisque ce n'est pas
seulement sur les JO que le propose le
gouvernement mais d'étaler d'aller
beaucoup plus loin et donc nous
considérons que finalement ici c'était
une experimentation il faut à la fin
l'expérimentation des jeux faire un
bilan en associant l'ensemble des
acteurs notamment l'active ça c'est un
premier un premier sujet et l'autre
sujet c'est que effectivement c'est
qu'est-ce qu'on fait ces données là et
avec elle jusqu'où on va dans les
données donc ça c'est un débat c'est un
débat qui était posé dans l'hémicycle
mes collègues socialistes sont
intervenus et on prendra une position
définitive encore une fois ce mardi pour
savoir ce qu'on en fait donc c'est un
débat d'ailleurs qui a débat plus large
c'est en fait de toute la aujourd'hui
c'est une vieille histoire c'est le
débat entre la sécurité qui est un droit
le plus élémentaire qu'il faut donner
aux Français et la liberté individuelle
et donc c'est l'état un débat donc il
faut là c'est pour ça que là dessus il
faut plus que jamais avoir des positions
très claires très clair Gérard Darmanin
a laissé entendre qu'il n'excluait pas
de recourir à la fin des fins des fins à
l'armée est-ce c'est vraiment le rôle
des militaires d'assurer le service
d'ordre des JO pour vous non mais c'est
pas le rôle c'est pas le rôle des c'est
pas le rôle des militaires puisque moi
qui suis membre de la Commission de la
commission des effets étrangères
défensifs on peut pas demander tout aux
militaire j'ai limité en joie d'abord un
il y a des théâtre d'opération sur
lequel nous intervenons donc il y a
également le bar également il y a
également l'opération sur le maintien
sur le territoire national donc il a
aussi été une vraie question moi je
m'interdis rien voilà ne sont pas
dogmatiques je considère que pour
reprendre les mots je crois du ministre
de l'intérieur quand une grande nation
comme la France je crois qu'on est en
capacité d'avoir je crois c'est 22000
personnels formés recrutés formés en
capacité d'avoir des mesures de sécurité
ces travail qui est devant nous et le
travail la respecter du gouvernement
aujourd'hui alors ce texte créé
également de nouveaux délits pour les
personnes qui s'introduisent sans
billets à l'intérieur d'un stade alors
forcément on est en mémoire le fiasco de
ce match Real Madrid à Liverpool au
Stade de France l'été dernier mais
est-ce que c'est pas aussi une manière
de utiliser les militants écologistes
qui voudraient se rendre visible pendant
cet événement
faut pas tout mélanger d'abord les
chiots c'est une belle fête et moi
encore une fois je suis fier comme mon
pays et en capacité d'être devant sur la
scène internationale d'accueillir un bon
un bon événement donc moi je pense qu'il
faut que tout le monde soit fier de cela
qu'on y contribue qu'on y participe
après il faisait attention à pas tout
mélanger donc moi je considère que
effectivement dans un stade ne peuvent y
pénétrer que ceux qui ont un billet je
pense c'est une bonne chose là aussi de
tombons pas dans la caricature et vous
n'êtes pas inquiet quand vous voyez un
peu l'état des transports en région
parisienne vous pensez que tout sera
prêt pour accueillir les JO en toute
sécurité et sans chaos moi je me suis
opposé je suis dans l'opposition à
Madame Pécresse qui est en
responsabilité depuis 2015 et transport
et vous avez raison de le dire elle
avait promis région de France pardon
elle avait promis la révolution des
transports c'est aujourd'hui la
régression dans les transports c'est
très inquiétant et moi aussi que je suis
comme vous inquiet j'ai envie de dire
malheureusement ni madame Pécresse et
les LR ni sous gouvernement là avec
Monsieur Macron non sûr régler le
problème des transports en France
aujourd'hui l'auto l'organisation de
transport en Île-de-France c'est la
région de France donc voilà mise à jour
j'ai bien compris que tout le monde veut
lui mettre tout sur le dos et ben madame
rien à se reprocher sur les transports
parce que elle fait comme tout elle
finance comme les autres mais celle qui
organise les transports c'est Madame
Pécresse donc ne font pas de là aussi de
faux débat à Madame dalgo dernier sujet
on va parler d'énergie puisque cette
semaine les sénateurs et les députés ce
sont mis d'accord sur une version
commune du projet de loi qui accélère le
développement des énergies renouvelables
alors on le rappelle ce texte simplifie
les procédures administratives
accélèrent le déploiement de l'éolien en
mer libère du foncier pour installer des
panneaux solaires par exemple au bord
des routes et puis après l'examen au
Parlement et bien le rôle des élus
locaux a été renforcé dans
l'implantation et le choix des zones
pour développer notamment les éoliennes
alors cet accord transpartisan la
ministre de la transition énergétique en
espagnol s'en est réjoui cette semaine
on va à côté
on a pu montrer qu'on était capable sur
un sujet qui était historiquement très
sensible de dégager un accord un accord
qui est au rendez-vous de l'histoire
c'est d'abord un gain de temps puisque
je prends l'exemple de l'éolien marin
les mesures que nous prenons vont
permettre de gagner plusieurs années sur
les projets c'est aussi une méthode de
planification qui remet les élus de
terrain au centre du jeu qui leur permet
de définir les zones où ils veulent
installer des énergies renouvelables et
lorsqu'ils le font des zones où ils ne
souhaitent pas qu'il y ait d'énergie
renouvelable et puis ce sont des
engagements inaccélération notamment
pour mettre des panneaux
photovoltaïques là où nous avons déjà
artificialisé les sols ou là où les sols
sont dégradés le long des routes sur le
littoral dans des anciennes sur des
anciennes décharges sur les parkings sur
les toitures donc c'est vraiment une
accélération de nos capacités à produire
de l'électricité bas carbone
architemment les parlementaires soci
sont les seuls à gauche à avoir voté
pour ce texte énergies renouvelable ça
veut dire que les socialistes peuvent
être constructifs avec le gouvernement
sur certains sujets non ça veut dire que
les socialistes sont depuis toujours
pour un mix énergétique nous sommes pour
une énergie décarbonée et nous sommes
pour le mix énergétique donc dans lequel
il y a du nucléaire mais aussi
effectivement des énergies renouvelables
d'ailleurs je rappelle que la ministre
obliger de rappeler que son texte entre
quand il est arrivé au Sénat et quand
les sorties étaient 20 articles arrivent
à 80 il a été sensiblement amélioré et
puis le rôle de la navette a joué ce
bien sûr ça ça son rôle donc en fait
c'est un texte de ce qu'on disons par
contre c'est qu'on nous aurions aimé
commencer par un débat sur la politique
énergétique française avant de faire les
segments parce que on fait c'est pas
grave on fait à l'envers puisqu'on dit
on parle l'énergie renouvelable on parle
nucléaire puis après on parle un petit
con générale mais encore une fois donc
nous les socialistes c'est c'est
historique c'est notre position nous
sommes pour le mix énergétique pour
avoir une économie décarbonée et
justement le gouvernement socialiste
avait fixé à l'époque cet objectif la
part du nucléaire doit représenter 50%
du mix énergétique or les sénateurs ont
voté un autre texte qui vise à accélérer
la construction de
droite la droite mais la droite
sénatoriale a contribué à supprimer cet
objectif de 50% dans de mix énergétique
pour vous regretter cette mesure où je
reviens à ce que je dis juste à
l'instant je pense qu'il faut non c'est
pas ça le sujet c'est que je pense qu'il
faut qu'il y ait un débat entre pays je
crois que ça passera par cette fameuse
loi qui nous est promise et à la fin de
l'année sur la boutique d'énergie
française il y a un sujet de petit lien
chez française en général il y a aussi
l'adversaire la question de quel outil
ce concrètement de faire qu'on s'est dit
ça est-ce qu'il y a des opérateurs
publiques qui sont en capacité de
fournir
globalement est à l'envers parce qu'on
fallait commencer par c'est quoi la
politique c'est quoi les objectifs et
après c'est comment
enfin je crois que tout le monde peut
comprendre quand vous dites mon objectif
est là-bas et vous commencez pas par
construire un bateau ou une voiture vous
dites d'abord je vais où puis après
comment j'y vais maintenant c'est à
l'envers c'est pas la peine c'est pas
grave nous ce que nous disons c'est
qu'il faudra qu'on est ce débat là il a
lieu à la fin de l'année nous serons
acteurs de ce déballage c'était mal pour
conclure justement sur ce sujet quand on
prend un peu de recul quand on voit la
situation nos fragilités en termes
d'approvisionnement énergétique est-ce
que ça pas été une erreur du
gouvernement socialiste et des
écologistes de limiter le développement
de l'énergie nucléaire et de fermer
Fessenheim il n'y a pas eu de limitation
on peut pas dire à la fois
correctement
on peut pas dire à la fois il faut faire
ce mix et pas prendre de décision bon
donc en même temps il y a des sons et
des prises on peut aujourd'hui la
contester c'est pas grave ce qui est
clair c'est que nous en France on a
permis et on permet de développer les
énergies nouvelles parce que sinon si
vous dites on ne touche jamais rien et
ça reste des des des simples discours ça
ne marche pas moi je suis à titre
personnel je vous dis je suis pour le
nucléaire j'ai pas de souci avec ça
allez on va finir en regardant et bien à
l'agenda de la semaine prochaine au
Parlement
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et lundi marquera donc le coup d'envoi
de la discussion du projet de loi sur
les retraites en commission des affaires
sociales avant l'examen en séance
publique prévue le 6 février puis le
président de l'Assemblée du crâne la
radasse sera à l'Assemblée nationale
mardi avant les questions d'actualité il
fera un discours devant les députés le
président de la Rada qui sera également
devant les sénateurs mercredi et la
veille le Sénat des battras de la
proposition de loi dites anti-squatte
contre l'occupation illicite de logement
avant d'examiner la proposition de loi
qui introduit le droit à l'interruption
volontaire de grossesse dans la
Constitution un texte venu de
l'Assemblée nationale et qui avait fait
l'objet d'une alliance entre la majorité
présidentielle et à la gauche c'est la
fin de cette émission merci beaucoup
archite et mal d'avoir été notre invité
et merci à tous de l'avoir suivi et on
se retrouve la semaine prochaine très
bonne semaine à tous ciao ciao
[Musique]